OOOOOOH! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
YEEEEEEEEEEES!
(pewds panting) yes yes yes best game!
Finally, a good game!
Screw you -
Mass Effect Andromeda!
Here we go. Here we go everyone. I hope you're ready
What the fuck is this? Why does this game seem like uh, Dead or alive?
ok let's play the actual game and see what this game is all about. I know what you're thinking: "Oh, it's another boob game haha"...no.
No!
It's not, it's way more, and if you say that I find that statement to be quite ignorant .
What is this an anime?
What is it shit? I don't watch a-ni-me!
uugh disgusting!
This is why i voted trump, to not see this gay shit. what the f-
What is this?
They're putting flowers on the grave.
Are they going to get naked soon, do you think?
Yes, YES, YEEEES!
hahAH
You can't go from funeral to ass. What is happening? Whoa-aoh!
You can't go from funeral to ass. What is happening? Whoa, whoa?
God bless. God bless. God bless. if this was just the intro can you even imagine the gameplay?
my God
It reminds me of when naruto and sasuke or fighting of this over the waterfall I
This reminds me of uh when naruto and sasuke were fighting over the- over the waterfall
I never understand how they can make those sounds with
*Japanese gibberish*
How is that racist for me to do call me a dumb bitch?
How?! is that racist for me to do?
Call me a dumb bitch,
What do the call a female swine, A sow, Call me that.
The writing..
It's so beautiful
It's unlike anything I have ever read.
I'm ready to fight -
Hey, you, you picked a fight with wrong YouTuber.
Imma getcha. And just imagine giant metal in here
And just imagine giant medals here
That's right, I'm gonna getcha
God fucking dammit
She has a shotgun
What is this, what? How did we get from that to this?
What is this gun?
Stop calling her a bitch
Look at her fucking battle stance.
I'm from the future.
I'm about to fuck you up, motherfucka
All right here we are finally again.
I like how you see the -
No, shame. No shame in this game.
Whoever had made this game.
It's shameless. There's no shame
No, shame, whatsoever, best game.
Best game of the year.
Best game universe.
Best game of all time of all time ever game.
Oh my God. Yeah, it ain't spawn one
How fucking many do you need to spawn? What the shit, where did they all come from?
All right, we're gonna have to we're gonna have to fight back, with the -
Yeah, why, why shoot the gun when you can, uhh..
fucking spin and shit
Hey!
Your titties out, bitch
Got 'em
Whoa!
Whoa, THEY GET NAKED!
THEY GET NAKED AS I SHOOT THEM!
BEEEEEESSSST
GAAAAAAYYYYMMMEEE
YES!
Keep shooting them!
Oh there's just one left
Got'em hahahaha
Uh, Shinobi Transformation!
HAKUGI-...HAKUGIBASHI!
Oh woah!
What the fuck?!
She gets giant tits!
That is the best thing I've ever seen in my goddamn life
Right there, wh- what I just d-
I'm not leaving this computer. You don't understand
You don't understand I am going to plug this game into my bloodstream
I'm going to eat the 3D printed food from now on.
Here we go
special attack
Hell, yeah look at that
damn
Fucking kick-ass!
And it's got nothing to do with my giant tits.
Are you always dancing, or is it just like a
Condition you have...
Is she wie-
oh I see it now. She has-
She has two guns in one hand and then she shoots them
Thank God. I can't see my underwears anymore?
Or can I? Let me see if I can.
You got to go close to a wall if you want to see like clothes that you guys cl-
Close to the wall ,change
the camera and then you uh-
No...sad...sad. I'm sad.
Holy sh-, Holy Shit look at me
This is some attack of the titans shit, man.
Look at this *speed noise*
Sonic's got nothing on this shit.
The music makes me so fucking pumped
This is like having cocaine.
I never had cocaine but I imagine this is not as good. I mean, this is better
This is better.
Don't do drugs.
Do anime.
Can you stand still like just for a second?
Jesus Christ...
*Gun Sound*
Anyway moving on moving on to the next battle.
I wonder people actually getting to the story
I'm really curious
Cuz I played the game only for the story nothing else.
Alright! So now we get to play.How about that...
After knocking an enemy back...
Okay.
Why are they so goddamn many of them?
Whoa! Look at that boi!
We're fighting on the water.
This is just like Jesus.
Jesus the anime.
What is happening?
Oh my God.
I-
What is happening right now?
I clicked the button and then-
-If you button mash, you will have a seizure
What is this?!
Oh I did it! okay? I did it! I'm naked now.
You know less armour makes you stronger everyone knows that.
Everyone knows that.
Historians have done it wrong all along.
Whoa, I surf?
Look at this! I surf!
I'm a fucking surfer.
Yeaah boi!
Yeah, boiii!
What up dawg?
I'm a surfing enemy fighting warrior Princess! ^-^
Can I ride the banana?
Answer me , dammit!
I can't, I can't ride the banana,
Perhaps later.
Yes, I leveled up. Yes
Been waiting so long to level up.
Level 100. I'm going for level hundred.
I'm not going to stop playing until
I'm level hundred.
I'm quitting youtube.
I'm going to play MLG Senran Kagura Estival Versus.
Here we go. Finish that bitch.
*japanese gibberish*
*Japense GIbberish*
What happened to the story of the game? I- all I got so far is naked girls...
...fighting.
I'm sure there is a story.
I-m-I'm sure of it.
I'm hundred percent sure there's a story here...
...somewhere...
Jesus Christ!
You can't be serious with that shit.
Is she wearing like a nazi outfit?
Like what is that supposed to resemble?
Am I the only one that sees this?
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Honestly ,what the fuck?!
Sure Wall Street is going to post about that.
I'm sure.
Justice to this game.
Some say that just makes the game better.
What do I know?
You know believe it or not?
I wasn't a Nazi before but after seeing that..
uhh...I might reconsider.
That was a joke...
T'was joke about anime titties.
That was anime titty joke.
I'm sorry. I'm- I'm- okay.
What's the actual fuck?
*weird screaming voice*  YeEAHh
God bless!
God bless America!
I mean Japan God damn it..
It wouldn't be-
it wouldn't be a Japanese game with the-
the slight rapey undertones.
What did I say?!
Asuka, do I look like a woman who's satisfied with her own boobs?
I'm gonna have to get back on that one.
Something's happening. Something's definitely happening.
It came from the sacred queendom of boobs
Well now I know where I want to go when I die. That's great
I've been looking into different options
Hell was pretty high on the list, but I uh- I think we got a new champion.
Secret Nazi
Secret Nazi! Did you see it? Do you see it? I see Secret Nazi.
What the fuck?!
You see it, don't you?
It's in the background.
In the pattern.
OK, Mission start.
Aim for a wall...
Wall run and with A.
Oh - woah.
Hoa!
Games!
Video games!
Video games are realistic!
Look at that boi.
Hahaha.
Look at this wall.
Ah
Trying to transform!
My God.
I can't
Ah!
Si-
*burp*
67 Metascore
An amazing game like it's a lot of media hate because our mainstream
"Professional Critics"
Are more worried about promoting their Social Justice Warrior Agenda
Than actually reviewing gameplay.
I rest my case.
I'm disgusted.
There is no God.
This game deserves its own rating.
Ok?
This- the rating system.
It does not go high enough.
Danny. What do you s-
What are you doing?
Well? I hope you enjoy this video...
If you didn't...
...Uhh, be sure to leave a like and a comment and...
...subscribe and if you did.